let me graph our coordinates in r2 so
let's see let me do it fairly neatly
i want to do it neater than that
so that is
my vertical coordinate
this is my horizontal coordinate it's
good enough and let's say i have four
points in r2 specified by four position
vectors so this is r2 right here so my
first position vector is the zero vector
so it just specifies the point right
there so it's 0 0
my second point is specified by the
vector
by the vector
say k
1
0 so some constant is times 0 let me
write it a little bit neater than that
a little bit bigger so it's k one
zero so that's my second position vector
which would specify that point right
there
so let me draw my vector right there
let's say my third point let's say my
third point is going to be up here as
you can see i'm creating a rectangle and
let's say it's specified by the position
vector draw the position vector like
that
and that position vector is going to be
the vector k
1 that's going to be its
horizontal component and then k 2
is its
vertical component this is if we wanted
to graph it on the coordinates this
would be the k 2 coordinate right there
and let's say that the last point
the last point is this point right here
and it is specified
by the position vector
0
k2
0 k2 and let me define
a set let me call that set
rectangle let's say r for a rectangle
let me just call it rec
let's say that rectangle is equal to the
set of all of the points when you
connect the points specified by those
position vectors
so the the rectangle
rectangle
formed
by
connecting
connecting points
points specified
specified
by
by these guys here so if we call this
vector a
this is vector b
this is vector
c
and then this is vector d right here
it's a rectangle specified by connecting
the points
now let's say so let me see let me draw
what our set rectangle is going to be
it's going to be
all of these points here all of these
points there all of those points there
and then all of those points there
including
are i guess you could call them our
vertices
so that is my rectangle
that is my rectangle now what is the
area within this rectangle so this is
the area
area
of
rectangle
what's the area within this rectangle
well it's just base times height the
base has length k1 right the distance
from here to here is k1 so it's just k1
and then what's the height it's the
distance from here to here which is just
k2 so it's just k1
times k2
that's fairly straightforward i haven't
shown you anything that fascinating just
yet let's say we're going to transform
this set we're going to transform this
rectangle and we're going to transform
it with the transformation
t let me pick a nice color for t
let's say we have the transformation t
it is a mapping from r2 to r2 and it can
be represented as so when you apply the
transformation t to some vector x
it is equal to the matrix
a
b
c d times
your vector x just like that now let's
see what happens when we apply the
transformation to each of these points
we saw many videos ago that if you want
essentially the image of our rectangle
under this transformation you can
essentially just get the transformation
of each of the endpoints and then
connect the dots in your codomain which
is also going to be r2 so we just have
to figure out the transformation of each
of these guys
so what is
my transformation i'll do it over here
i'll do it in the colors
what is the transformation applied to
the zero vector
applied to point a right there
well it's just going to be let me just
it's going to be a times 0 plus b times
0 which is just
0 and then the second term is going to
be c times 0 plus d times 0 which is
just 0.
that's point that's vector a
vector b
vector b if i apply the transformation
to vector b
vector b is k 1
0 just like that if i apply the
transformation it's going to be a times
k so the first
first entry in the transformed vector or
what we're mapping to in our codomain is
going to be a times k1 plus b times 0 so
it's just a
k
1 and then the second entry is going to
be c times k 1 plus d times zero
so it's going to be c times k1
all i'm doing is taking the matrix
vector product of this guy and that guy
and then let's move on to
point c so the transformation of point
c
of k1
k1
k2
is equal to or the transformation of
vector c we could say it's equal to what
the first entry is going to be a times
k1 plus b times k2
a times k1 plus b times k2 and the
second entry is going to be c times k1
plus d times k2
c times k1 plus d times k2 we have one
point left
the transformation if we take the
transformation of our vector
0
k2
what do we get we get
a times 0 plus b times k2 which is just
b times k2 and then c times 0 plus d
times k2 which is just d
times k2
just like that so let's draw the image
of our rectangle under our
transformations let me redraw my axes
so this is my vertical axis right there
this is my horizontal axis right there
and so a gets mapped to the zero vector
right there so this is the
transformation
this is the transformation of 0 0
right like that now what does the vector
b get transformed the vector b gets
transformed to a k 1 c k 1. so let me
draw it like this
the vector b gets transformed to
something that looks like this
where this is the vector
so this is the transformation
of
k1
and 0 which is equal to a k1
c k1
saw that already now what does this
yellow guy get transformed to let me do
the blue one first so the blue one gets
transformed
here let me make let me finish here so
this is going to be if we come down here
this is going to be a k1 right there if
we go to the left like that that's going
to be ck1 that's how we graph it now
this last guy this blue guy
maybe he looks something like let's say
he looks something like this
he looks something like this this is the
transformation of that vector right
there by this linear transformation 0
k2 which is equal to
which is equal to the vector b k2
and d
k2
so this point right here is b
k2 and then this
coordinate right there is d k2 now this
last guy this yellow point when i
transformed it what do i get
i got ak1 plus bk2 so ak1 plus bk2 will
get you right about there so that's
going to be its x coordinate and this y
coordinate is ck1 plus dk2 ck1 plus dk2
so ck1 and then i'm going to add
i'm going to add that much again to it
so it's going to get me someplace over
here so i'm going to add this distance
to this whole distance over here so i'm
going to get up here some point so i'm
going to get right over
here so that vector is going to look
something like that
it's going to look something like that
that is the transformation
of k1 k2
that's the transformation of that guy
and then if we connect the dots remember
the transformation of this set of this
rectangle or we could say the image of
this rectangle under the transformation
we just take each of the points that
define that rectangle and then we
connect the dots
we saw that a while ago so
this let me draw it this way
this
line right here that connects those two
dots will be transformed to this line
that connects these two dots right there
this line
let me i was going to do that in a
different color
this line that connects those two dots
is going to be transformed to this line
that connects those two dots
and then we have this line that connects
those two dots
is going to be transformed to this line
that connects these two dots right there
and then finally this line that connects
these two dots is going to be
transformed to this line that connects
these two dots right there
now just out of curiosity what is so let
me just write this right here so this
rectangle right here is the image we
could write this as
t of our rectangle
or if we want to write in words this is
equal to the image
of the rectangle of rectangle
under
under our transformation t
now what is the area
what is the area
of
the image of our rectangle under our
transformation
what is the area of this thing what is
this area
right there
well we could view this parallelogram
essentially as a parallelogram generated
by this vector
and that vector
right or we could if we want to write
another way if we had a matrix
if we had some matrix whose column
vectors are this guy and that guy so
let's say
its first column vector is this guy so a
k1 c k1 and this one right here this was
the transformation
of k1
0
and then its second column vector is
this guy
is this guy right here
which was
b
k 2
and d k 2.
this
this parallelogram is a parallelogram
generated by these two column vectors
this was the transformation right here
this was the transformation of zero k2
right and in the last video the last
video we said that the area of this
parallelogram is equivalent is
equivalent to let me write this right
now so the area of the parallelogram
which is the same thing as the area of
the image of our original rectangle
under our transformation the area of
this parallelogram is equivalent to the
absolute value let me call this
determinant right here let me call this
i for image
so it's equal to the absolute value
it's equal to the absolute value of the
determinant
of the determinant of the matrix whose
column vectors whose column vectors
generate that parallelogram so it should
be equal to the determinant of
our the absolute value of the
determinant of i we saw that in the last
video that's what the area of this thing
is going to be
well what is the area what is the
determinant of this
well this is going to be equal to got to
keep our absolute value signs so it's
the determinant of this is a k1 times
dk2 so it's we could write this as let
me switch colors
we could write it as
k1 k2
a d
a d all i did is multiply that term
times that term minus this term times
that term
so minus say k1 k2 bc
k1
k2
bc that's just the definition of the
determinant of a 2x2 matrix and we saw
this in the last video this is nothing
new here or maybe it might be relatively
new if you just watched the last video
but all i'm saying is look if we want to
figure out this parallelogram this is
the parallelogram generated by that
vector and that vector and if we say
that those two guys are the column
vectors of some matrix right there we
saw in the last video that the area of
this parallelogram is equal to the
absolute value of the determinant of
this matrix now what is this equal to
this is equal to we can factor out a k1
k2 so it's the absolute value of k1
k2
times
times a d
minus b c
now what is this equal to
well a d minus b c
a d minus b c that is the determinant of
our transformation vector
so if we say that t of x if we call that
vector right or our transformation
matrix if we call this matrix a we call
it if we call it a this is equal to
this is equal to
k1 k2 times the determinant
of a
which is a pretty interesting takeaway
what this is telling us is look if i
have some
some region or in this case i just have
the rectangle but if i have some region
in my domain and i apply a
transformation let's say my region has
some area
it says some area let's say in this case
it has some area a well let me let me
write this let me write this as area
this was my original area in my original
region right and then i apply some
transformation to it where the
transformation
where the transformation is equal to
some matrix a
times any member of your domain i apply
some transformation to it i get some new
region i get the image of this of this
set under my transformation your new
area your new area is going to be equal
to
the absolute value of the determinant
of your transformation matrix that's the
tr that's the determinant of the
transformation matrix that's the
transformation matrix
transformation
matrix
so it's equal to the determinant of the
transformation matrix times the area of
your original
of your original rectangle in this case
times the area of your original
rectangle in this case right this was
your original rectangle you take the
absolute value just because sometimes if
you flip swap these
these these vectors you might get a you
might get a negative sign so you take
the absolute value but that's a really
neat idea the determinant the
determinant of the transformation matrix
is essentially a scaling factor
on an area on on the area of a certain
region i'm not going to prove it to here
but you can kind of imagine it
if i have let's say i have some let me
go abstract now
let's say i have some region
in
r2 that well let me do a better let me
do a
shape that you might recognize let's say
i have
let's say i have something like that
this is it's a bit of a it's let's say
it's an ellipse
right and this is our domain
this is my domain it's r two and let's
say that the area here the area of this
region right here
is equal to a so area is equal to
a
and let's say i have some transformation
t that is a mapping from r2
to
r2
and t is defined so
t applied to some vector x in my domain
is equal to well i used already used a
so let's say it's equal to some matrix b
some matrix b times any vector in my
domain
if i take the image of this area under t
so this is my domain right here let me
do it in the co domain let's say the
image of this under b let's say it looks
something like or my image under t let's
say it looks something like this i don't
know what it's going to look like but
let's say it looks something like this
let's say it looks something like that
right there so this is
so this right here
so if we call this set let me call it e
for ellipse that's this whole thing
right here this is the ellipse
right there this is the image of my
ellipse
under the transformation t if i take
every point of this ellipse i'll
construct this right here or
i guess maybe just to keep the analogy
straight for this for this example let's
say that the ellipse is the set of just
the boundary
of just the boundary but it also applies
actually if you were to fill up the
whole region so this boundary gets
mapped to
gets mapped to this boundary right here
but it would have worked just as well if
we filled up the region since i'm not
proving either to you very rigorously
you don't have to accept it as a leap of
faith so this is the image of this
boundary under our transformation and if
the area surrounded by this boundary or
if you say the area of this region is a
then the area here
the area
of the image of our of our ellipse under
our transformation is going to be equal
to the absolute value
of our area our original area right
there times the determinant
times the determinant of our
transformation matrix
times the determinant of our
transformation matrix and if you're if
you find it a little bit of a big leap
to go from just a arbitrary rectangle
transformation to maybe these more
generalized shapes you can imagine you
can so t is going from there to there
it's always nice to draw that arrow
but if you kind of don't if you see it
view it as a bit of a leap to make that
jump from rectangles to curves you can
imagine this shape to be able to be
constructed by a bunch of
by a bunch of arbitrary rectangles
so you could you could essentially fill
this space with a bunch of arbitrary
rectangles
with a bunch of arbitrary
rectangles like this
and you could keep making them
infinitely small
so that you completely fill the space
right you completely fill that space
with rectangles and if you were to map
each of those rectangles using t each of
those rectangles might look something
like
this
maybe they look something like this i
don't know what they'll look like
they'll look like a bunch of
parallelograms
maybe i'll look they'll look something
like that
no i'm not drawing it that neatly
they'll look like a bunch of
parallelograms
and they will essentially fill this
space right there so that's the way you
can get your head around the idea of
kind of jumping from just the arbitrary
rectangles to these you know these
arbitrary curves or shapes or regions
but this is a pretty neat outcome and
it's a very interesting way to view a
determinant a determinant of a
transformation matrix is essentially a
scaling factor for area as you map from
one region to another region or as we go
from one region to the image of that
region under the transformation